long before daybreak cubans began
walking to the plaza of the revolution
after a two-year hiatus brought on by
the pandemic cuba's communist party and
government spared no effort to make this
annual may day march one to remember
healthcare workers led the parade in
front of revolutionary leader raul
castro
the still influential former president
and his chosen successor miguel
diaz-canel standing side by side as a
symbol of continuity
[Music]
there were the familiar chants of
loyalty to deceased leader fidel castro
and against the u.s government's
decades-long economic embargo against
cuba
we will defend our socialism as we have
for 61 years for fidel and raul cuba is
one of the few countries in the world
that still marks international workers
day like this but make no mistake
there's very little for the average
salaried worker in this country to
celebrate right now because this country
is witnessing one of the worst economic
depressions in its history
[Music]
intensified u.s economic sanctions the
pandemic and a monetary reform that has
sharply reduced workers purchasing power
have led to soaring inflation
and unleashed the largest exodus of
cubans since 1980.
the communist party continues to say
that the state-controlled sector will
save the economy and it's not true the
young people all want to leave they've
lost all hope
cubans are expected to take part in the
may day march and are generally brought
here from their place of work
but like annie bex there are those who
say they still believe in cuba's system
because i'm convinced that this is the
country that i want to defend that's why
i'm here to support my leadership and my
people
and during these hard times this march
clearly aimed to send a message to
domestic and foreign opponents that
cuba's government is still able to
mobilize large numbers of its people
lucia newman al jazeera havana